Okay. So, let's start with the joint probability.
Now since A and B are both dependent
on each other, there are only two possibilities.
Both can be heads or both can be
tail, tails. So the joint probability is also 0.5. What
is the, what is the conditional probability? Conditional probability is given as
probability of A comma B upon probability of B. So,
conditional probability is 1. Now, what is the entropy
of A? It is similar to the last example, because
we are still using fair coins. So, the entropy of
A is 1. Entropy of B is also 1. What
is the joint entropy between A and B? Okay. Let's
use this formula, and see if our answer changes. Okay,
the joint entropy comes out to be 1, which is
different than our last example. What is the conditional entropy?
The conditional entropy is given by this formula. Let's substitute
the values to find out what we get. Okay, the conditional
entropy comes out to be 0. What is a mutual
information between A and B, then subtract the entropy of A,
and the conditional entropy of A given 0, which is
1 minus 0, which is 1. So the, so the mutual
information in this case is 1, while in the previous
case, it was 0. So since these coins are dependent on
each other, the random variable A gives us some information about
the random variable B. This tells you, how mutual information works.